you know silicon valley tends to be
liberal every everyone knows that and
the reason for that is that there's a
tremendous number of entrepreneurs there
and entrepreneurs tend to be high in
openness and lower in conscientiousness
so they're creative but they're also
willing to break rules you know which
you kind of have to do often hopefully
not to a criminal extent but you have to
well you know it's tricky when you're
trying to establish something new
because look at a company like uber you
know they had to bend the rules to to be
successful and those companies that have
rented those scooters out and put them
on the streets everywhere you know they
just kind of went ahead and did it it's
not something an orderly person would do
because they'd ask for permission
whereas the people who started these
scooter rental companies just said well
what'll happen if we put them everywhere
and the answer was that seemed to work
but you know
you have to have a rule-breaking
proclivity in order to manage that